bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors enquête pour
subornation de témoin que reproche-t-on
exactement l'ancien président colombien
ce qu'on reproche à oribe alors qu'est
ce qu'on lui reproche pas parce que il
faut savoir que c'est pas la première
affaire auxquels est confrontée au river
mais c'est la première affaire dans
laquelle il va y avoir une mesure de
justice donc l'assignation à résidence
derrière lui ce qu'on lui reproche c'est
dans le cadre d' accusations qu'il a eu
avec un sénateur de gauche d'avoir
subordonnés des témoins c'est à dire
d'avoir créé des faux témoignages pour
ce pour justement enfin faire la
diffamation contre contre se sénateurs
notamment avoir avoir conclu plusieurs
plusieurs témoins alors c'est la
première affaire où on voit le prêt de
l'ancien président uribe qui se retrouve
en fait un peu face à la justice qui va
enfin devoir rendre des comptes à la
justice et pour le peuple columbia en
tout cas quand on connaît son histoire
récente
ça peut en tout cas représenter que des
choses très positives puisque uribe
comme j'ai dis qu'est-ce qu'il qu'est-ce
qui le qu'est-ce qu'on ne bougerait pas
le fait d'avoir souvent des témoins ça
c'est peut-être le l'accusation lalala -
pears si j'ose dire parce qu'on l'accuse
auxi de lien avec le narcotrafic rapport
le de liens de deux mesures d'assassinât
d'avoir corrompu aussi la presse
plusieurs mesures de corruption avec des
multinationales
enfin c'est vraiment là le sommet de la
ribera été mis en cause pour d'autres
faits bien plus graves complicité dans
des massacres lien avec le narcotrafic
écoutes illégales justement pourquoi
cette affaire devant la justice
intervient tel maintenant et pourquoi
pour ce motif
et bien parce que le rapport de forces
qu'on en vient tout simplement changé
depuis l'époque uribe os qu'il était en
plein pouvoir avec l'appui des forces du
narcotrafic et de ses milices qui lui
permettait d'avoir un plein pouvoir et
d'être très populaire en colombie on a
vu depuis quelques années une
contestation sociale forte en colombie
une fracture sociale qui a mis la
population contre les les forces
politiques un phénomène description on a
vu notamment un mouvement social très
puissant aux comptes
en décembre janvier derniers d'ailleurs
sur des thématiques à ses proches que le
mouvement social qui a aussi touché la
france puisque c'était des questions de
retraite et de maximisation du marché du
travail
voilà les derniers élections les
dernières élections municipales sont pas
très bien passées pour la droite dure 10
20 ok il faut savoir que il va le dock
est un peu d'une certaine manière le
successeur d' horribles et on peut
certes un même disque que horrible lui
chuchote encore à l'oreille pour la
gestion du pouvoir et cette contestation
fortes qui existent en colombie a mené à
un rapport de force nouveau est
aujourd'hui arrivée n'est plus
l'intouchable qu'il était avant en
battant le peuple colombien et celle
enfin entre sur la scène politique et
conteste du coup c'est oligarchique qui
a qui a dirigé la colombie pendant des
années et des années et qui a conduit à
un pays qui a conduit à ce que le pays
soit extrêmement inégalitaire malgré ces
chiffres économiques qui était jugée
comme bon puisque tout l'argent va aux
multinationales la violence politique
est énorme les accords de paix qui n'ont
pas été content respecté et que et que
uribe avait dénoncé enfin voila c'est
aussi ce ce rapport de forces est
fracture sociale qui existe des
structures institutionnelles qui
existent a ajouté en plus récemment avec
la question du coût vide puisque la la
gestion du coc vide et particulièrement
en combi est absolument catastrophique
on est à onze mille morts
les mesures historiques daury b qui
avait été de privatiser des services
publics notamment de la santé on voit
les conséquences aujourd'hui
donc du coup uribe n'est plus
intouchable et c'est tant mieux
justement si l'accord iv est condamné il
attend toujours la date de son procès
est ce que ça voudrait dire il n'y a un
peu la fin d'un cycle en colombie et
bien moi je pense que il est possible
que ce soit le premier domino qui tombe
et qui va et qu'il faut s'arrête le
premier domino côte qui tombe et qui va
laisser place à une flopée d'autres
domino qui voit aussi tombés tout à fait
parce que uribe et d'une certaine
manière la la grande personnalité de 2
qui représente en gros c'est sept colons
qui l'a associée au narcotrafic
corrompus dans les idées néo-libérales
atlantiste proche des états unis qui
vend son pays aux multinationales qui
pour les richesses de son pays aux
multinationales contre les indices
une très violente politiquement contre
les féministes et écologistes les
syndicalistes
évidemment les anciens phare qui veulent
qu'ils veulent la paix les lélés grand
pacifiste uribe représente ça et donc
c'est pour ça que sa chute d'une
certaine manière pourrait tout à fait et
à juste titre mené à la fin du de ceux
de ce modèle et on voit de plus en plus
aujourd'hui la halle à la contestation
de ce modèle notamment avec lé score de
la droite qui sont pas qu'ils commencent
à baisser on voit l'affirmation de plus
en plus de force ce gauche que je pense
notamment à nos organisations soeurs qui
est de colombiens au malin avec les
figures comme petro m'arriver a causé à
la sénatrice et c'est là où d'autres et
donc du coup effectivement et à juste
titre il est possible que cette mise en
examen de deux oiseaux cette année son
assignation à résidence ensuite la date
de son procès de uribe puisse mener
effectivement à renforcer la
contestation sociale profonde qui existe
dans ce pays qui en demande de
changement et puisse mener a enfin fait
ressortir la colombie de ce cycle
éternel de néolibéralisme violences
politiques mesures anti écologiste
narcotrafic et c'est génial et pierre
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
national du parti de gauche responsable
international des jeunes insoumis merci
à vous